nous sommes le jeudi 12 septembre
bienvenue si vous venez de nous
rejoindre sur TVfil 78 nouvelle édition
du 78 lactu voici quelques uns des
titres que nous allons développer au
cours de cette édition le syndicat FSU
des Evelin tire ses premiers bilans sur
la rentrée 2013 une rentrée qu'il juge
plutôt décevante dans un contexte de
réforme des rythmes scolaires le
syndicat appelle notamment à plus
d'organisation à une revalorisation du
métier
d'enseignant déconfitur du foie gras des
sirop le château de Versailles se lance
dans l'épicerie fine des produits seront
bientôt commercialisés sous son nom et
pas uniquement en France une façon de
diversifier les sources de revenus et
puis vous allez le voir ces élus ruraux
qui sont en colère ils étaient une
trentaine mardi devant l'Assemblée à
manifester contre le projet de la
ministre Cécile du flot d'obliger les
communes de plus de 1500 habitants à
avoir 25 % de logements sociaux de quoi
défigurer le parc naturel de la Haute
Vallée de Chevreuse selon son président
qui sera tout à l'heure en plateau avec
nous on débute vous en avez l'habitude
par l'image du jour la bergerie de
rambouyaaki lance son passeport annuel
15 € pour les adultes 10 € pour les 4 12
ans et un accès illimité pour aller se
promener en famille autre avantage les
événements exceptionnels seront à moitié
prix la bergerie qui mise clairement sur
la fidélisation de ses visiteurs
quelques 100000 par an la bergerie
propose également les 28 et 29 septembre
une rencontre agro-écologique cette
pratique qui vise à promouvoir la
qualité sur la quantité et à prendre en
compte dans le développement agricole la
protection de l'environnementan arartus
Bertrand est attendu le samedi
conférence table rond animation aussi
bien pour les familles que pour les
professionnels on quitte la bergerie
pour faire le point sur la rentrée
scolaire le syndicat enseignant FSU a
décidé de dresser ce bilan entre rythme
scolaire et recrutement quels sont les
difficultés qui subsistent yolen Torz et
Patrick de
DIM il qualifie la rentrée de décevante
64 nouveaux postes ont été créés dans le
département c'est bien mais trop peu
pour le syndicat FSU d'autant plus que
la récente réforme des rythmes scolaires
exige plus d'acteurs sur le terrain mais
aussi plus d'organisation des éléments
pas assez pris en compte selon le
syndicat il a observé les premières
difficultés dans la commune de trappe
par exemple mercredi dernier
la cantine centrale a été obligé de
préparer en catastrophe de à 300 repas
parce que le le calibrage des repas
n'avait pas été fait de façon
satisfaisante le matin donc les derniers
enfants on mangé à 2h de l'après-midi on
fait le même constat le soir au moment
de de du départ des enfants où les
parents ne savent plus où ils doivent
aller où certains enfants ne savent pas
non plus où ils doivent aller et donc d
raté selon lui pour le moment les choses
ne sont pas claires ni dans la tête des
enfants ni dans celle des parents des
horaires plus simples et homogènes
seraient souhaitables pour les syndicats
autre point noir soulevé le manque de
candidats au concours d'enseignants une
réalité plus importante pour les
mathématiques et la technologie résultat
à l'académie de Versailles manquerait
d'enseignants et recruteraiit davantage
de contractuels pour assurer les postes
vacants je crois que la crise du
recrutement elle est liée à la
difficulté du métier mais surtout à la
question salariale un professeur
aujourd'hui débute avec un peu plus de
1600 € alors qu'il est recruté à bac+ 4
ou 5 une tendance qui ne se retrouve pas
dans l'enseignement privé où les
salaires sont plus élevés selon le
secrétaire ces solutions revaloriser le
métier d'enseignant et donner une
véritable formation aux nouvelles
recrues une formation qui serait à la
fois pratique mais aussi
théorique autre point presse aujourd'hui
12 septembre celui du président de
l'agglomération de saint-quenttin en
Yveline le socialiste Robert Cadalbert
il a adressé ses priorités pour les
prochains mois a commencé par l'emploi
jeune et puis également un coup
d'accélérateur à l'économie Catherine
zulato et Julien
Leroi la rentrée sera économique ou ne
sera pas c'était le maître mot de la
conférence qu' a tenu ce jeudi le
président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de saintquanttins en
Yveline Robert Cadalbert tout d'abord
1000 emplois supplémentaires avec
l'arrivée du nouveau siège social de
Mercedes France à montigy le Bretonneux
la de la fameuse étoile emblème de la
marque est fixée à la fin novembre
toujours des emplois supplémentaires
cette fois du côté du Crédit Agricole
une extension est prévu pour accueillir
1000 salariés en plus la pose de la
première pierre à Guill encour qui
lancera le chantier fixé au 22 octobre
autre nouvelle elle concerne le
Technocentre Renault à Guy encour un
projet de rapprochement des sites
franciliens vers le PO ivelinois est
envisagé cela semble se confirmer des
collaborateurs du site de RIL mal maison
devrai commencer à arriver enfin la
vente des terrains pour la la création
de l'école d'ingénieur estaka à Montini
a été signée à la fin du mois d'août la
pose du premier arbre symbole là encore
du lancement du chantier est prévu le 15
novembre les jeunes une priorité pour le
président de l'agglomération qui s'est
fixé un objectif très ambitieux qu'aucun
jeune cinquantinois ne sorte du système
scolaire sans un contrat c'est une
logique atteignable estime-t-il tout le
monde sa veut dire d'abord le tissu
économique de 5tinvin avec des acteurs
le club face qui effectivement
travaillent dans l'insertion des jeunes
dans l'entreprise on on fait en sorte
que tous les contrats d'apprentissage
puissent effiquement trouver des des des
des entreprises on fait que les les
emplois d'avenir que l'école la 2uxème
chance que pô emploi tout le monde avec
la cité des Cité des Métiers euh sous
lesgidees importante de la Mission
locale qui fait un excellent travail
aujourd'hui B travaill ensemble des
bonnes nouvelles qui ne font pas oublier
deux dossiers sociaux du moment la
session de rware le centre informatique
d'Areva Guill encour les syndicats sont
très mobilisés sur la question et la
restructuration du groupe EADS implanté
notamment à la clé Saint-Pierre à
hencour on va continuer à parler de
politique mais aussi d'urbanisme avec
l'invité de ce journal Yvan de valal
bonsoir vous êtes le président du parc
naturel de la Haute Vallée de Chevreuse
conseiller général des ivelines
également vous faites partie de ces élus
ruraux qui s'opposent au projet de
remanement de la loi SRU de solidarité
urbaine proposée par la ministre Cécile
Duflot dans le détail commune de plus de
1500 habitants et qui appartiennent à
une communauté de communes de plus de
50000 habitants vont être obligés
d'avoir 25 % de logements sociaux d'ici
une dizaine d'années d'ici 2025 sous
peine forcément de fortes sanctions
financières mardi vous étiez devant
l'Assemblée avec d'autres élus pour
manifester et fait exprimer ce ce
mécontentement en quoi aujourd'hui ce
texte vous pose problème écoutez c'est
extrêmement simple en fait c'est une
sorte de bavure législative si je puis
dire euh l'obligation de construire des
logements sociaux dans de toutes petites
commune rurale ne correspond évidemment
pas à la volonté réelle du législateur
c'est la combinaison de plusieurs textes
de loi dans le temps je peux pas rentrer
dans les détails ici qui fait que
effectivement quelques communes rurales
comme CERN la ville par exemple qui ont
fait le choix d'entrer dans la
communauté de communes de Rambouillet se
trouve du jour au lendemain soumise à
l'obligation de construire 25 % de
logements sociaux elles auraient choisi
d'aller à Chevreuse elles ser serait
aller à la communauté de commune des
étants elle ne serait pas soumise à
cette obligation c'est donc je dirais
une bavure L et ce que nous souhaitons
c'est que par voie d'amendement et nous
comptons sur les parlementaires
évelinois pour le faire que par voie
d'amendement on corrige effectivement ce
qui constitue une erreur dans la loi
alors là il y a quelques communes très
précisément où cela pose problème vous
avez cité CERN par exemple mais
globalement ce que vous craignez c'est
quoi une urbanisation très forte dans un
parc protégé alors en fait on a deux
deux questions il y a d'une part les
communes qui sont directement concerné
par cette mesure qui sont une poignée
pour pour ces communes c'est dramatique
c'est un doublement de la population en
une dizaine d'années alors que
normalement elles sont très éloigner du
centre c'est strictement confort
contraire au SDRIF au schéma directeur
de la régionale de France c'est
évidemment contraire à la charte sans
compter que construire massivement dans
ces communes 25 % de logements sociaux
c'est énorme il n'est pas certain que ça
réponde réellement à des besoins ceci
dit il manque des logements aujourd'hui
a la place dans le parc naturel bien sûr
vous avez tout à fait raison il y a
beaucoup de place dans le parc naturel
régional la question c'est de savoir si
des gens voudront aller habiter très
loin sans moyens de transport et sans
emplois à proximité et c'est bien ça le
défi il y a effectivement une demande et
le Parc Naturel Régional s'emploie
effectivement à développer des logements
sociaux et c'est dans sa charte mais
c'est dans des proportions qui sont des
proportions raisonnables on vise 10 %
c'est d'ailleurs conforme au schéma
directeur la région -de France la
proportion de logements sociaux dans le
parc naturel dans votre parc régional de
la Haute Vallée de chevau est plus ou
moins respecté aujourd'hui
non non non le le parc accuse un retard
effectivement on n'est pas à 10 %
aujourd'hui tout simplement parce que
c'est lié aussi à l'histoire beaucoup de
communes rurales du parc se sont
développé sous forme de lotissement
pavillonnaire dans les années 60 70
voilà c'est un fait historique
aujourd'hui on nous dit c'est pas bien
d'avoir construit des pavillons à
l'époque à l'époque tout le monde
trouvait ça très bien bon voilà il faut
accepter ça prend du temps mais le parc
s'y emploie faut accepter ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez peur de logem
sociaux est- les élus de ces communes on
pe ai de voir du tout le parc depuis une
dizaine d'années nous avons des
réalisations exemplaires et nous avons
travaillé avec l'État pour densifier les
loottissements pavillonnaires pour
mettre au point de nouvelles techniques
qui sont très innovantes donc si vous
voulez notre problème n'est pas
qualitatif on est d'accord pour
accueillir des logements sociaux notre
problème dans ces communesl il est
quantitatif ce sont c'est une explosion
de la population qui est ingérable pour
les pour les a dans la mesure où leurs
équipements collectifs ne sont pas
suffisants où il y a pas de moyens de
transport il y a pas de transport en
commun c'est absurde vous parlez de
bavure législative est-ce que vous avez
rencontré la ministre Duflot par exemple
pour é dossier éc j'ai écrit à Madame
Duflot avec les maires d'ailleurs nous
avons écrit au printemps et on a reçu
une fin de nous recevoir assez brutale
cet été dont je dirais que j'ai
l'impression que je suis pas certain que
la ministre avait réellement regardé le
dossier nous avons rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine au cabinet du ministre
de l'environnement j'espère que l'on
aura une meilleure écoute et l'on pourra
trouver une solution législative à un
enjeu fort modeste parce qu'en réalité
on parle d'une poignée de village donc
au total le nombre de logements n'est
pas considérable rapporté à l'échelle de
l'Île-de-France mais si chaque commune
se mobilise de la sorte pour cibler des
points très précis vous comprenez aussi
que ça va forcément poser problème pour
la réalisation de ces logements sociaux
non c'est peut-être la logique de la
ministre non si vous voulez vous avez
des vous avez des communes importantes
qui sont soumises à la loi SRU par par
exemple vous avez le Menil saint est
soumis à la loi su Manil et am mais ils
ont déjà dépassé le seuil je crois vous
avez également S et chevreuses qui sont
donc par conséquent si vous voulez on
sait gérer c'est en cours en revanche si
on veut de la cohérence que l'on
m'explique pourquoi il faut faire autant
de logements sociaux à cner la ville et
que des communes posées sur une voie
ferrée desservie pour une gare comme les
essard le roi et le Péret ne sont pas
soumises à cette obligation donc on est
dans un système absurde et je vous dit
c'est un angle mort de la législation
ces communes au lieu d'être àambouillet
elles seraient allé à Chevreuse elles ne
seraient pas soumise à l'obligation donc
l'enjeu clairement ça n'est pas la
quantité de logements sociaux à faire
sur l'ensemble du territoire du parc
c'est un angle mort de la loi le
calendrier est très serré il faudrait
vite pour vous pour vous faire entendre
pour modifier lég non non on a on a
quelques mois devant nous puisqu'en fait
la loi àure le débat a commencé mardi
en première lecture à l'Assemblée il
doit repasser au Sénat il reviendra
devant l'Assemblée donc à priori je
suppose que l'on a selon le calendrier
parlementaire habituel quelques mois
devant nous et on va citer aussi
Jean-Frédéric Poisson député de la 10e
circonscription des ivelines du côté de
Rambouillet qui a prévu he déjà de
déposer de nombreux abonnements pour
obtenir justement gain de cause
concernant la construction de ces
logements sociaux on va aussi profiter
de votre présence sur ce plateau pour
aborder un autre dossier vraiment
politique Valérie pcrè que vous
connaissez bien puisque vous êtes son
suppléant pour l'assemblée a publié
aujourd'hui aux éditions Albin Michel
voulez-vous vraiment sortir de la crise
derrière ce titre un inventaire des
années Nicolas Sarkozi elle a été
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur du
budget élu député des Yvelines vous avez
siégé à l'Assemblée lorsqu'elle était au
gouvernement dans ce livre elle écrit
notamment nous avons manqué de courage
et d'audace en parlant des choix pendant
le quinena est-ce que vous partagez son
avis oui on ne s'est pas concerté mais
je partage ce constat j'avoue que sur
certains dossiers je regrette qu'on ne
soit pas allé plus vite et plus loin
hein
euh on a bien avancé sur certains
dossiers comme l'enseignement supérieur
et la recherche elle elle évoque par
exemple le dossier de l'abrogation des
35 he il aurait fallu le faire ou encore
la suppression des postes dans
l'éducation il aurait fallu limiter ça a
été fait de ma de manière trop comptable
selon elle oui la la question de la
suppression des postes dans la fonction
publique effectivement mériterait d'être
conduite avec beaucoup plus de
discernement et non pas selon une
méthode comptable non le bilan si vous
voulez euh on a réformé l'enseignement
supérieur je crois que c'était très
positif
vous avez également des lois qui sont
très importantes pour stimuler la
recherche comme le crédit impôt
recherche qui est très efficace en
revanche sur certaines réformes majeur
je suis souvent intervenu à l'Assemblée
pour demander qu'on avance sur ces
dossiers en va bon c'est le sort d'un
député effectivement sur les 35 heur sur
la TVA sociale qui aurait permis
d'améliorer considérablement la
compétitivité de nos entreprise et qui
aurait permis de créer de l'emploi
paradoxalement vous êtes satisfait
aujourd'hui que une ancienne ministre
Val PC fasse le bilan de ce quinquena
est-ce qu'il fallait faire le bilan de
ce quinquena ça été la question durant
l'été hein tout le monde ntait pas
d'accord au sein de l'UMP oui écoutez je
vais vous dire c'est quand même pas
vraiment le sujet le passé le passé si
c'est pour en tirer des enseignements
pour l'avenir en se disant ça c'est bien
il faut continuer ça c'est mal très bien
mais aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est
effectivement présenter un programme
crédible au français parce que la
politique en a bien besoin autre député
des ivelines Henry gu dans la trè
circonscr pour lui Nicolas Sarkozi hte
tous les esprits est-ce qu'il hte le
vôtre à l'UMP est-ce que vous attendez
le retour de Nicolas Sarkozi non écoutez
moi de de ce point de vue là si vous
voulez il y aura des élections en temps
et en heure je suis
pas soumis à une quelconque influence je
jugerai en temps et en heure et sur un
programme et juste avant de vous laisser
repartir on va évoquer alors on va se
projeter un petit peu hein ce sera du 2
au 4 octobre le Congrès des parcs ce
sera organisé dans votre parc le parc
naturel de la Haute Vallée de Chevreuse
vous allez réunir l'ensemble des parcs
régionaux quel est l'objectif ben
écoutez le chaque année les 48 parcs
naturels régionaux de France se
réunissent pour leur congrès annuel
c'est l'occasion de faire le point sur
la situation de ce point de vue-là cette
année on a une grande inquiétude qui
figure également d'ailleurs dans la loi
en examen au Parlement jusqu'à
maintenant les les chartes des parcs
devaient être devaient être respecté
c'est-à-dire que tous les documents
d'urbanisme devait être conforme à la
charte cette obligation est supprimée
dans la loi actuelle et donc aujourd'hui
la Fédération des Parcs se bat depuis
des mois et également nous souhaitons
des améliorations législatives sur ce
point et ce sera l'un des points
principaux du rendez-vous au ministère
de l'Environnement lundi prochain et
puis ensuite le Congrès des parc Studio
au 4 octobre merci vaneval d'être venu
sur ce plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
donc opposé avec d'autres élus he de ces
communes rurales au projet de loi sur le
logement à ces modifications apportées
par Cécile du flot qui prévoit la
réalisation des logements sociaux dans
les communes de plus de 1500 habitants
et du fait et de ce fait forcément les
communes qui sont au sein du Parc
Naturel seraiit concerné pratiquement du
du jour au lendemain une dizaine
d'années pour réaliser ses logements
sociaux merci à vous d'être venu sur ce
plateau le château de Versailles qui se
lance dans l'épicerie fine une gamme de
produits vient d'être dévoilé alors des
fruits des légumes encore des bonbons et
des confitures exemple de prix 11,90 €
pour un sirop de la Vand à la vanille
une licence qui doit permettre de
diversifier les ressources de
l'établissement le reportage d'Antony
res et de Patrick Jacques de
dixm du sirop de la vente des nefles ou
encore des Panet autant d'aliments
oubliés des cuisines que vous n'avez
certainement jamais dégusté et pourtant
sous le règne de Louis XIV ces produits
étaient dans toutes les assiette le
château de Versailles lance sa gamme
épicerie fine et veut leur redonner vie
tous les nouveaux fruits et légumes que
nous mangeons aujourd'hui ont été
introduits à versaill par jeanm la
Cantini des pratiques comme le foie gras
on été porté par par Louis XIV des le le
sucre les bonbons les sirops ont été
développé sous le règne de Louis XIV
cette gamme épicerie fine est également
un moyen pour Versailles d'exporter son
savoir-faire à travers le monde avec 75
% de visiteurs étrangers le château veut
rayonner en dehors de nos frontières
grâce à la gastronomie royale ça fait
partie des atouts de la France ça fait
partie des points forts de la France et
nous à Versailles puisqu'on est
l'emblème de la France et bien on se
doit aussi de savoir exporter la
gastronomie exporter des produits qui
certains amateurs seront peut-être déçu
ne sont pas 100 % versaillais mais sont
bio et cultivé dans le sud-ouest de la
France pour les déguster il vous en
coûtera en moyenne entre 7 et 15 € la
pièce des confitures des compotes il
existait déjà auparavant également des
parfums quelle limite jusque où peut-on
décliner cette marque château de
Versailles quels sont les produits qui
pour vous pourrai porter un la belle
Julien Leroi est allé vous poser la
question à versaill forcément bah les
produits laitiers oui avec le parc du
château ave l'ancienneri de la reine je
crois qu'il y a une ferme donc
éventuellement des yaourt fromage de
chèvre ce genre de choses et produits
dérivés effectivement avec le
lesestampill du château de Versailles ça
pourrait être une idée effectivement
mais versaill moi je pense à ouais les
bénisteries la
marquinerie la passementterie ce qui
faisait dans le temps quoi des produits
qui sont ont fait fabriquer à Versailles
bah oui comme la tradition où les il y a
des confitures la charcuterie j'en vois
pas beaucoup d'autres des produits dont
dont la France est bien réputée pour sa
finition des vêtements des choses qui
impliquent un savoir-faire français et
particulièrement en terme de rayonnement
on reste à Versailles et c'est un enfant
de la ville qui est venu présenter son
nouveau film le réalisateur Xavier de
Lausanne était présent à la première
projection au cinéma le Roxane d'enfant
s valise c'est un documentaire sur la
scolarité difficile de ces adolescents
migrants qui vivent en France avec
beaucoup d'espoir véroniqueurbide a
rencontré Xavier de Lausanne pour TVfil
il est aussi revenu sur ses débuts et
une carrière débutée non pas derrière la
caméra mais derrière les fourneaux
et bien à l'âge de 15 ans j'avais deux
choses qui m'intéressaient beaucoup qui
était la cuisine plus particulièrement
la pâtisserie et le cinéma et en fait je
me suis engagé dans la cuisine enfin
j'ai fait une école hôtelière parce que
ça me semblait plus pragmatique mais euh
en rentrant à l'école hôtelière j'ai
toujours su que en fait j'allais faire
du
cinéma alors enfantvise en fait c'est
ces enfants qui sont souvent tiraillés
euh entre des parents qui sont à
l'étranger et puis d'autres parents qui
sont en France et donc c'est souvent des
enfants qui font la navette je suis ici
sa fille 2 mois je viens du Congo
brasaville ça je pas rencontter ça comme
ça c'est une longue histoire maman
elle est
oublé la seule chose qui m'intéressait
c'était de découvrir ces personnages
découvrir ces jeunes qui arrivent en
France et savoir un peu dans quel état
d'esprit et à quoi elle se confrontait
je trouvais ça intéressant avant d'avoir
enfin avant de se construire peut-être
des avis sur la question d'immigration
de savoir de qui on parle
dans la vie c'est pas tout facile pour
que tu iras qu'est-ce que tu veux il
faut que tu battre et ben c'est ça c'est
çaement le
cas et vous retrouverez prochainement
sur notre antenne l'intégralité de cette
interview dans l'émission VIP du cinéma
à la télévision M6 poursuit la diffusion
de son programme la meilleure
boulangerie de France et le seul
représentant des ivelines c'est un
artisan de Houdan il a même déjà atteint
la finale régional le tournage des
épreuves a déjà eu lieu la diffusion est
prévue ce vendredi en fin d'après-midi
cler Cambier et
limoine il est 8h Jean-Luc est au
fourneau depuis maintenant plus de 4h
des horaires difficiles mais ce travail
le passionne depuis maintenant 30 ans sa
boulangerie est située à Oudan mais la
renommée de Jean-Luc a largement dépassé
les frontières de sa ville depuis le
début de semaine lundi on a pu les
découvrir dans l'émission la meilleure
boulang de France sur M6 inscrit par des
clients il fait partie des 84 boulangers
sélectionnés dans l'Hexagone je me suis
retrouvé dans la sélection début j'y
croyais pas trop je me demandais ce qui
se passait je pensais qu'il y avait
plusieurs boulangers de ma ville et on
m' dit non vous êtes le seul des
evelines donc wouh la grosse pression
parmi les épreuves il a dû préparer des
spécialités de la maison je vous
présente la nukatum c'est une brioche
que j'ai fait pour l'émission donc c'est
une brioche au Nouga avec des brisures
de Nouga de la Brico sec pardon et des
noisettes torfiées une brioche qu'il a
créé lui-même face à deux autres
boulangers il a su convaincre le Jéri
prochaine étape la finale île-de-fance
diffusée ce vendredi à
17h35 pour le moment il savoure sa
nouvelle notoriété des clients AFF flu
de Paris ou encore de chartre pour
Jean-Luc c'est aussi le moyen de créer
de nouvelles vocations ça va faire
découvrir notre métier parce qu'il a été
beaucoup délaissé à une époque par les
jeunes parce que c'est un métier
difficile pour travailler le weekend
travaill la nuit et tout mais en même
temps c'est c'est un beau métier quoi
moi quand je me lève le matin je suis
heureux de travailler quoi Jean-Luc
cherche d'ailleurs à grossir son équipe
l'appel est lancé victoire ou non lors
de la finale cet artisan continuera à
réaliser ses gestes quotidiens avec
plaisir on pèse les bacs à 6
kg et après la machine est divise pour
faire une répartition des
points quand j'arrive du premier coup je
je me sens s surhumain un surhomme
peut-être pas mais un passionné oui et
bonne chance à lui forcément un mot de
sport pour terminer ce journal du
baseball les coupgard de Montini et le
Bretonneux qui sont maintenant dos au
mur ils disputent les play-offs de 2e
division en cas de défaite ce weekend
ils n'auront plus aucun espoir de monter
Anthony
rche après le froid de cet hiver et la
longue interruption de l'été avant les
play-offs les organismes minimontains
semblent user mais à quelques jours
d'une demi finale retour décisive
arnaaufo l'entraîneur des cougard
préfère oublier la déception du match
aller et va tout faire pour remobiliser
ses joueurs tout le monde est peut-être
un petit peu fatigué oui mais bah une
finale ça ça vaut le coup quoi
donc les remotivés on peut pas motiver
quelqu'un qui l' pas mais je su sûr
qu'ils sont tous un petit peu motivés ce
que je essayer de faire c'est de les
rallumer rallumer la petite flamme
qu'ils ont au matchal cette petite
flamme avait quitté les inimontains
manquant d' ité de précision ils se sont
inclinés par deux fois à PAC les
demifinales de Division 2 se jint au
meilleur des 5 matchs les cougard ne
doivent plus perdre pour espérer voir la
finale est complètement de ha mur mais
il faut gagner TR matchs tant que c'est
pas fini on est encore là on a joué chez
eux on va jouer chez nous à
Montini on a quand même j'all dire tout
mais non on a quelques points de notre
côté quand même la survie des cougard
passe d'abord premier match coup près ce
samedi après-midi au Stadion maréchal
pour ne pas vivre une fin de saison
cauchemardesque fin de cette édition du
Journal du 12 septembre n'oubliez pas
dorén avant lactus c'est également le
vendredi je vous retrouve donc demain
aux horaires habituels et puis sur
internet avec le Twitter et le facebook
de TVfil 78 bonne
soirée